home burglary leads to a house fire and
the alleged suspects are caught on
camera seconds before happened early
sunday morning near tropicana and nellis
the family now wants help tracking down
those involved victoria saha live in
studio here with this exclusive story
what used to be a family's cozy home is
now charred and covered in ash and the
family tells me it is because two
thieves broke into their house and then
set it on fire after walking away with
their electronics
everything just looks from like from a
horror movie it is the only way javier
luna can now describe the home he shared
with his girlfriend and daughter
basically
we thought it was just breaking and
entering but once we got here and our
family members saw through the
window they were surprised they were
scared because everything was trashed
everything was burnt luna and his
girlfriend were away last weekend with
poor cell service once they had access
to their phone their ring camera showed
this video of two people in their
backyard you see one peeking through the
back window and then turning the camera
around this is where i believe they
broke in they tore this off and just
basically cut it after stealing their
laptop and ipad fire officials tell luna
the suspects at the fire in the living
room a space luna and his family loved
we would just eat here
just spend most of our time here not to
see it like this is
sad i wouldn't want anyone to go through
this the melted couch and charred walls
is now a reminder that those moments
have now become memories this is evil i
mean we would have been okay if they
would have just stole like
just a couple things and leave
they think the estimated cost of the
damage is 300 thousand dollars they did
file a police report today which shows
this is considered arson clark county
fire department is also continuing to
investigate if you would like to help
the family out we do have information up
on our website on how to do that in the
studio victoria saha live local now